it's the largest internment of
minorities since World War two more than
1 million ethnic Weger Muslims
locked up in specially set up prisons in
China's northwestern region of Xinjiang
recent weeks have thrown up even more
evidence of these camps leaked Communist
Party papers reveal amongst other things
instructions from the top on showing
absolutely no mercy in Xinjiang yet the
camp's continue the question is why
there's been lots of condemnation but
little action the US House of
Representatives has passed a bill to
impose sanctions against Chinese
officials Turkey has denounced what
China calls reeducation camps as a quote
great shame for humanity but is that
enough in a moment I'll be asking a
German MP if Germany should be doing
more but first this report looks back at
the anatomy of a cultural genocide for
thousands of years they've been here
Turkic we Gers worshipping trading
growing up and coming of age living in
Xinjiang province western China for
thousands of years they've been here
Turkic we Gers worshipping trading
growing up and coming of age living in
Xinjiang province western China
no they face a fight for their very
existence its roots in 2009 when the
washed ethnic clashes in decades rocked
the region soldiers were deployed as
revenge attacks left almost 200 people
dead
the brutality shot the nation and
provoked a fierce response from Beijing
President Xi ordered a security
crackdown reportedly saying use the
organs of dictatorship show no mercy
before long vast prison complexes began
springing up their inhabitants guilty of
being Weger Muslims a former guard
describes the subjugation mean everyone
was innocent they hadn't done anything
no crimes no transgressions nothing like
that but the camp forced you to find
something inside yourself that you were
guilty of lose left behind began sharing
videos of themselves with disappeared
family members the torment palpable
[Music]
elsewhere on the Internet evidence of
cultural destruction emerged to
thousands of mosques gone Muslim graves
erased religious garments ban the
demolishing must means no religion no
Islam in the region so this is a crime
this is war against Muslims one of those
locked up recounts the daily routines of
indoctrination i thinkin when we got up
in the morning what we had to say things
like thank you long live ji Jinping
after the national anthem only then
would we be given soon
all the while love stories remain on
hold China insists its operations in
Xinjiang are necessary to read out
terrorists and extremists and it says
the prisons are voluntary reeducation
camps with its students free to leave
even as pictures like this suggest
otherwise but perhaps it's the silent
suffering of children too young to
understand and wives longing for their
lost husbands to return which tells its
own story joining me now is Gerda Jensen
she's an MP and the chairperson of the
German parliament that's the Bundestag
human rights and humanitarian aid
Committee miss Jensen welcome to DW
NewsAsia
now the US House of Representatives has
passed a bill to impose sanctions on
Chinese officials and condemn the
treatment of wiggers in Xinjiang do you
think it is time that Germany did
something similar it is time for a
Chancellor Merkel to put it on the
agenda of the upcoming European Council
to talk about a common European
perspective on imposing sanctions and I
wouldn't oppose these talks about
sanctions definitely not and you have
made that point clear earlier but then
is a joint European solution the only
way what is preventing Germany from
acting on its own well I would love to
have Germany act on its own and also
take steps for a European common answer
to these human rights violations in
China so far Germany has not stood up I
hope that Chancellor Merkel will do so
the upcoming week but so far I am very
certain that we need a common European
answer because China it is we're talking
about over a billion people and a
European answer would be a balanced way
to to have an answer
- China definitely let's just try and
focus on what German you could
potentially do you said Germany has not
stood up
why has Germany not stood up well at
first I think we need to think about the
chronology of these capsules so we are
just thanks to great journalists we know
about these camps for certain now and
China has lied so far about the
existence now they cannot do that
anymore
and since then I I suppose that Germany
wanted to wait until their certainty now
that we have certainty and now we need
to also talk to well to the companies in
province of Xinjiang to resync maybe
their values if there is any linkage
between the prophet and of the economic
profit and the you guys that are being
detained there in the camps and this
point in time where Germany can only
wait and say well we're waiting for the
certainty that is over and I hope that
miss Merkel will step up we have an
upcoming session week in Parliament next
week and maybe the Parliament will also
be able to to focus on that because we
have the human rights the International
Human Rights Day coming so I hope that
the Parliament will step up there
there's a lot of hope coming from you
and potentially hopefully this is
realized but I just like to go back to
the point of what is holding Germany
back there's something like 5,200 German
companies that are currently active in
China and China is Germany's largest
trading partner we talking about trade
around 200 billion euros do you think
that this is an obstacle that the German
government will be able to overcome I
hope and there is only hope you can hear
from me from the opposition side that
Germany will overcome that I urge the
companies also also to rethink and
overlook their values because at the
long-term I think that the rule of law
democracy and human rights should be put
higher than
the only economic profit because we see
that China is a dictatorship and you
never know how economic growth can
develop in a dictatorship and that's why
I hope that also German companies
European companies will not tolerate
these gross human rights violations in
China miss Jenson the other head of the
German parliament human human rights and
humanitarian aid committee is there
something you could do in your position
could you bring forth a resolution
potentially forcing the government to
discuss this and potentially pass
sanctions well we can definitely bring
forward a motion we are currently
working on that in our FTP party and
hopefully we will discuss that the
upcoming session week to urge the
government to introduce maybe sanctions
but also to bring it to the agenda to
discuss what the international community
could do and your European community
could do so far that hasn't happened and
I would propose that this should be the
step forward so first discussing it
having it on the agenda and if China
doesn't react to anything and does not
take responsibility we definitely need
to talk about sanctions and that's why
we leave it for the time being Gilda yes
and thank you very much for speaking to
us thank you